which is a slight decrease from march um
greg the administration has tried all
sorts of things in terms of the language
to try to say you know this is what this
is what you're really seeing but
i think when you see the videos and you
talk to the actual people
i tend to think that that carries more
weight what do you think i
agree with you completely and this is a
lot like what we said in the uh
earlier block which is there's when the
when you can't solve a problem if the
other side
doesn't see it as a problem they they'll
give it they'll give it lip service but
they it's just like the gas lines that
means reduced consumption
in this case it's like oh you we don't
have much of a border
that's not so bad but when you're
talking about the video
like the videos that we share and and
other people
say oh uh videos of abandoned children
in the mountains
and they say well that's clearly out of
context i want to know what kind of
context
would make that video better were they
on a kid's version of outward bound
were they part of a nature hike that we
weren't aware of i don't think there's a
context
that makes these videos better and then
finally where is executive action joe
he can stop all of this right now but
he's too scared of his far left flank
uh he could beef up the border he could
reverse the reversal of policies
and old joe would do do that
but woke joe can't do that okay katie do
you see
or hear of any sort of urgency on behalf
of anyone in the administration
no i don't i think that they think this
is an acceptable problem you had joe
biden saying on the campaign trail that
the country can absorb two or three
million new people
yeah kamala harris giving in to this
abolish ice movement rhetoric
saying that they need to rethink how
that that uh that agency operates and
you're seeing
that happen right now and it's one thing
to see all these
families and children turning themselves
into border patrol but what happens when
you have thousands of people a day down
in new mexico and arizona
who are paying smugglers to get them
into the country without being detected
those are the people you really have to
worry about and when it comes to how
this impacts
americans you know you have a lot of
these people getting flown to small
towns
overwhelming resources you have
democratic mayors even saying look we
can't handle this influx of people
and americans are trying to get back to
work with with everything that's been
going on
and illegal labor depresses wages for
american workers and so
there are consequences to this but
there's no urgency from the
administration
at all when it comes to solving this
problem and i don't think they see it as
a real problem
there are people one like andrew
sullivan for example who are trying to
get
the administration to um sort of rise to
the occasion here
um but in your opinion juan is the
administration doing all its can all
that it can yeah
i i don't know i mean i'm really puzzled
because you know i just trust in your
good will but
i don't there is a problem at the border
let's all agree at that and then you
have an administration that's trying to
take steps to deal with a surge
and right now all the numbers indicate
they're making
progress you know we talk about the
arrest at the borders well
that's evidence that we have law
enforcement
protecting and keeping the border closed
we saw most of those people who were
arrested turned back they were not
allowed in the united states
now you look at the number of not only
children
but teenagers migrant families all three
decreased numbers over the last month
what are you seeing in terms of even uh
you know
all of this it seems to me is an
indication of when we
even allow the children to stay because
of our values as americans we're not
going to
do harm to children we're not going to
go back to separating children from
their parents
those were who were being held by
customs and border patrol
now at a new low and we are processing
those people more quickly
okay that's all progress i just think
that when you think in those terms
you say yeah go america go and now we
need to get congress to go
congress go get involved let's fix the
immigration system in this country
jesse there i would imagine given that
so many unaccompanied minors have come
across the border and been abandoned by
their parents
that there are more families separated
now than before
that's true everything juan said is spin
nothing he told the audience has any
truth to it it's all just trying to
obfuscate the facts
and here are the facts in the context we
have now held
two straight months of 20-year highs
we're near 180 000 border crossers
a month two months in a row of that juan
likes to think that that's
progress that's not progress imagine how
many are getting through
they're not expelling juan of the 178
000 that we caught 70 000 of them
biden led into the country 70 000 of
them that's like 40
of the ones we're catching we're letting
in and think about all the other ones
that are going around
what you're saying about unaccompanied
minors is also not true
we've had two months in a row of
all-time highs
18 000 and then 17 000.
you're calling that progress that's like
saying the nationals
got blown out by 18 runs and then the
next day got blown out by 17 runs
that's not progress those are all time
defeats and those are record-setting
defeats
this is easily solved if he just says we
will not allow unaccompanied minors in
and fly them back or just remain in
mexico he can do it right like that
but he's choosing not to
love the sports analogy conversation to
be continued
yes i'm sure we will okay sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else